[Music]
this video
was going to be one of my most favorite
videos that i've ever posted
it is something that made me so happy
but it also has brought me so much
sadness that i
can't even really put it into words
it's been a few days and so this video
is basically
showing you guys kind of the story of
this hummingbird nest that
i found in my backyard and unfortunately
something happened and the babies didn't
survive
and they oh my god i don't even like i
hate talking about it but i really
wanted to share this video with you guys
because
it is something that made me so happy
and so many of you were like
sharing this journey with me we were
live streaming on twitch i think we
almost hit like 300 hours
i kind of just like left you guys
hanging with this whole
twitch stream it was really traumatic
because we had all
had invested so much time and so much
heart and so much love
into these little birds and then you
know for this
tragedy to happen a lot of you may have
never
had to deal with grief or loss of a
loved one or
friends or pets or anything so grieving
for some of you may be something that is
new so anything that you're feeling
it's totally normal it's confusing don't
be afraid to cry
don't be afraid to ask for help or talk
to someone
and being able to do that and for us
here to just kind of connect and grieve
together
is something that i think is very
important and i just want you all to
know that i love you guys
so much and for just sharing this
beautiful journey
with all of us here online and i just
want you to know that kiwi is still out
there
and it just is the most heartbreaking
but also like the most beautiful thing
to just kind of still go outside my
backyard and she's still there
so a little over a week ago i discovered
a hummingbird nest in my backyard and i
can't even tell you
how i felt when i found it like i
actually started getting emotional i
almost cried because i've never seen a
hummingbird sit still before
not only that there were two eggs in
there i was out of town for about
three weeks on a road trip with my
sister and when i came back
this was here waiting for me and i
started doing a live stream over on
twitch and like at this point it's been
going for over a week we witnessed
both of the eggs hatching live when the
first one hatched the first day we were
all losing our minds
and with a little bit of research the
chat was like hey there's a really good
chance that this other egg is going to
hatch tomorrow so once the eggs are laid
there's about a 13 to 17 day period
before they hatch so we found this
nest at the most perfect time ever here
she is behind me this is
kiwi and her two babies which currently
have not been named at this point and
what's really weird is i don't have
any like hummingbird food on a feeder
like there's nothing
that i've ever done to bring them here
now after finding this nest i also found
three others in my trees i feel like i
have some sort of weird wildlife
sanctuary that i didn't
even know existed back here wait is that
something else what's that right there
that also looks like a potential other
one that has fallen off
this is so that's five how in the world
do i have five
freaking hummingbird nests like
they must have been nesting here for a
very long time i didn't even know it
kiwi could have actually been born in
one of these nests and now she's back
having her babies oh my god i'm gonna
cry
so the crazy thing is anytime i come out
here and she flies away like
i can spot her up here just watching so
it's like she
no there she's over there she's up there
she's over there she's over there you
see her you see here
she's over here some may say justine are
you losing your mind and i'd say
maybe she's gonna zip over here real
soon
there she is there she she goes there
she goes there she goes that's what's so
crazy about this it's so hard to capture
a hummingbird on camera and the fact
that she just sits here and hangs out
and feeds her babies
and we've been watching her for almost
200
hours live on twitch it's fascinating
it's it's absolutely fascinating so
here's the stream setup i'm streaming
everything off of this surface book 3
and this thing has been on for over
200 plus hours at this point i haven't
even turned the screen off
like i've been pushing this little
laptop
to its absolute limits it's connected
with an elgato capture card which is
going outside
to my sony a7s iii with a 70 to 300
millimeter lens on now when i started
this i was using the a7 3 and it kept
overheating and i didn't really want to
put
my brand new a7s 3 out there but i had
to do it
for the nest cam i'm also working on a
couple of upgrades for this
i'm going to add a webcam here so i can
do some live streaming and live
commentary over top of
the baby bird stream i'm gonna be
getting a 600
millimeter lens that i'm borrowing from
sony to be able to really
get in that nest like i wanted to feel
like we're inside of it and what's so
weird is watching this stream
you can't really see how small these
birds actually are
these birds weigh absolutely nothing
like the eggs were almost like the size
of tic tacs
it's crazy this bird has brought me so
much joy like i can't even
explain it and it's so cool to be able
to share this with you and seeing
all of the comments in the chat has been
so fun and i love that you guys are also
invested in this as well and i think
today in this video we're going to
officially name
the babies so stay tuned let's open up
that webcam
and get this set up so here it is it's
usb and it has adaptive light sensor
1080p
60 frames a second also hdr enabled a
nice
wide-angle lens with an adjustable field
of view usb
3 and flexible mounting options which is
very important for
you know commentating over top of
baby birds i love this flexible mount
because you can mount this to a tripod
or you can even just kind of set it on
the back of like your monitor or your
laptop
oh this unscrews too so if you want to
add this just to a tripod
stand alone you can do that or you can
add the flexible mount back on and
there's also
a little tripod attachment here as well
so many
options oh it's got a little lens cap
too
that's nice
[Music]
bird stream is about to evolve yet again
let's go set it up
about just the webcam for the first time
and this is so quite i plugged it in
and it auto installed auto recognized
and then i downloaded the razer synapse
app which will
let me get some more in-depth controls
with this camera but really i don't need
it i just
added it into stream labs and we're
ready to go
we are now going to name the babies live
i have a few duo names
right now but we need two more duo names
the webcam here test oh my god the beam
they're feeding they're getting fed
they're feeding they're feeding they're
feeding they're feeding
oh feed the back one the back one needs
fed yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're getting your meal have
your meal hi guys
welcome to the stream so i'm actually
recording a youtube video right now we
need
two more duo names you guys keep saying
mate but that's like so so obvious
you know kahlua and cream that's cute
egg and other egg
that's it egg and other eggs
we got to get the pool all set up so
guys this is a very big moment the
babies are going to get their name
what do we name the babies frapp
and chino mochi and matcha
coffee bean
dude that's my vote lemon and lime and
egg and other egg here we go
i'm voting coffee bean and tea leaf not
to like sway your votes
coffee bean and tea leaf is very close
to my heart
oh my gosh emily is here she has just
raided the channel with
12 viewers hi emily i think lemon and
lime are winning right now
shoot we've only got a few more minutes
left
jenna's saying voter fraud
no mail in ballots here it's just you
know suggestions
stop the count someone is suing for
defamation of the lemon and lime name
history repeats again oh my gosh
we stole the voting
i'm losing my mind oh this is the
suspense
is actually killing me i am gonna go to
coffee bean and tea leave after this if
it wins
and we have ourselves a winner ladies
and gentlemen
coffee bean and tea leaf has
kiwi named your babies coffee bean and
tea leaf
well i guess i'm gonna go to coffee bean
tea leaf now how do you guys feel
it's closed i used to drink my lattes
here
i would sit by the fire and enjoy it
and now there's no enjoying
so it looks like my favorite coffee bean
and tea leaf is closed
guess the baby names are now a tribute
let's go find another one that might
actually be open
[Music]
so we're going to be approaching a
coffee bean and tea leaf
that appears to be open there's a sign
that says we're open
[Music]
this one's for you kiwi and coffee bean
and tea
leaf babies
it's here tears here it's here tears
here it's here's here's here
no what
have we here hey justine is this
necessary
absolutely this is my life all right
little guys
we have got something for you
i had to shut the stream down it's quite
tragic so
we're we're dark for a minute this might
be the biggest lens i've had on this
camera
because in what world do i ever need a
600 millimeter
which world is that was it this one
oh my gosh we are so freaking close to
this nest
you guys are going to lose your minds so
look at the difference between the 300
to the 600 unbelievable
[Music]
the quality of this lens is unbelievable
like i can actually see the feathers on
these babies like i can the detail
it's just overwhelming
[Music]
[Music]
there's apparently like hummingbird hats
that you can wear
and they will like feast out of your hat
this is new information to me
i made this little note it's a little
bit weathered at this point
but i made this for the gardener because
i didn't want them to do any sort of
gardening on my fake grass that may
potentially disturb the babes
cheers so sad
i have to end this video this way
this is something that i was so afraid
of happening and
it did i can't even look outside
something not
messed up last night unfortunately the
babies they didn't make it
there's a clip of it on twitch i guess i
think something just kind of either
jumped on the branch and knocked it down
[Music]
it's been like such a traumatizing week
but
coming out here and still seeing kiwi
fly around
and we might have spotted her with a boy
hi kiwi oh my baby oh i'm so happy to
see her
it warms my heart like just seeing her
still here she hasn't left she hasn't
given up
and just kind of seeing her move on has
sort of helped me move on
like i know that some people are like
this is crazy
how are you so invested in these birds i
don't know honestly like they
they captured my heart they captured all
of your guys's hearts here on the
internet i just wanted to show you guys
kiwi and show you that she's doing well
and she's still here and we've seen her
flying around with a boy
and i think she might be looking for a
new place to nest
so kiwi i think has moved on i'm sure
she's grieving as all of us have
it definitely has been a very tough week
i'm not gonna lie
just like trying to process it and not
sure
if i should share it with you guys or
anything but this video was so beautiful
and it was so special to me so i'm so
glad that you guys were able to come
along for this journey
and share kiwi and her babies and maybe
just maybe
we'll have another nest and i will
protect that nest
with my own life
[Music]
you